Ratko Mladic was in court against his
will and determined to cause trouble
first he refused to testify then said
he'd speak if god's fetched his dentures
from his cell once his teeth were in
place he refused again to give evidence
citing ill health and the fact he's also
a defendant mr. Millar did do you intend
to refuse to answer every questions that
are supposed to be put by mr. Karras
I'll give the same answer to every
question the former Bosnian Serb
military leader faces charges of
genocide as does his former political
boss Karadzic prosecutors hold them
responsible for the massacre of 8,000
Muslim men and boys at Trevor Anita in
1995 large ignored the questions
addressed to him about that and then
reacted angrily when the court refused
to let him read out his statement thank
you for stopping me saying what I wanted
to say you've confirmed my assumption
that the Hague Court isn't a court of
law it's a satanic court on the face of
it summoning laddish as a witness has
done nothing to help Karadzic defense
but both share a common goal and that's
to make life as hard as possible for the
tribunal